what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some very interesting and
possibly very exciting news in the DC
and the Marvel world today as James Gunn
has expressed that the Guardians of the
Galaxy cast will most likely work with
him over at DC now I for one think that
this could potentially be extremely
awesome I would love to see some of
these actors be over in DC in that
Superhero world but what does this mean
for the Guardians of the Galaxy and the
MCU well if you've kept up to date with
all of the news that's happened recently
with Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 what
James Gunna said what the cast has said
well then you most likely know that it
definitely feels like a lot of the
Guardians are going to die now the
Guardians of the Galaxy team isn't going
to go anywhere they're simply just going
to get new members and some of those
members will be the current original
members but not all will survive in fact
we're all pretty sure Drax is gonna die
Dave Batista has talked about moving on
from the role many different times kind
of hinting that his character is done
and palm clementif has even commented
that even after this movie it's not over
over basically telling us that it is
kind of over but what this really means
is that it's over for a few of the
characters and new characters are going
to come in and join the team like Adam
Warlock in fact I'm starting to think
more and more that Adam Warlock and
Gamora are going to have some type of a
love romantic relationship with each
other much like they do in the comics
because keep in mind this is not the
same Gamora that Star-Lord fell in love
with and who fell in love with Star-Lord
so I'm expecting some big twists here
but James Gunn has expressed interest in
working with Chris Pratt over at DC in
fact he said he probably going to he
literally said probably but what does
this mean for Chris Pratt's Star-Lord
well does that mean that he's going to
die now this doesn't necessarily mean
that this doesn't necessarily mean
Star-Lord is going to die of course it's
possible for a Marvel actor to also be
an actor in the DC Universe as well
however based off of the trailer that we
got for the Guardians of the Galaxy and
based off of James Gunn basically
telling us this is done this is the
final Guardians of the Galaxy movie in
his franchise at least we've heard him
say this is the last Guardians film for
him and a lot of the cast and here is
the thing yes it is possible for actors
to be in both universes however Studios
might not exactly like that they don't
like mixing up characters so people kind
of get confused for example Robert
Downey Jr is the icon of Iron Man if he
appeared as let's say Batman it might
cause some confliction with some fans
however Christian Bale of course was The
Dark Knight and he ended up being Gore
the god butcher in Thor love and thunder
so it's possible however that character
was only in one movie and didn't look
anything like Batman so although we did
know that some of the Guardians of the
Galaxy were going to die it makes us
think now more than ever Star-Lord might
actually be one of the characters who
was going to die as well now if you're
curious as to what exactly James Gunn
said here's what he said on Twitter when
referring to the Guardians of the Galaxy
he said this cast are like my family I
cannot tell you how close I am to Chris
Pratt and palm clementiff and Dave
Batista and Zoe Saldana and Karen Gillen
but I also know I will work again with
all those people individually again
probably at my other job now if you're
not aware James Gunn has recently been
announced co-ceo of DC Studios him and
Peter Safran so James Gunn is in charge
of DC and he's actually made this pretty
clear that nobody else is making
decisions about what happens in the DC
Universe but him he stated on Twitter
not too long ago nobody can interfere
except himself because he is in charge
so if James Gunn wanted Chris Pratt to
play Batman he could make it happen no
one would stand in his way no one can
stand in his way but James Gunn I think
is being very smart about this entire
thing I think he's got a real great plan
that he said he is going to reveal this
month now in this plan I don't think
we're going to hear anything about any
of the cast members for Guardians of the
Galaxy joining the DC Universe this is
probably a little bit down the line for
example James Gunn has already stated
that he's basically doing a reboot of
the DC Universe talking about how we're
going to have a new Superman movie with
a new Superman who is going to be a
younger Superman so we can assume that
most of these new characters which are
really old characters coming into the
rebooted Universe like Wonder Woman
Batman Aquaman cyborg The Flash although
we have no idea what's going on with
Ezra Miller at DC right now but we can
assume all of these characters in the
reboot are going to be younger
characters so we can assume that Chris
Pratt and the cast of the Guardians
aren't going to be playing any of these
characters I don't think Zoe Saldana is
going to be Wonder Woman and I don't
think that Chris Pratt is going to be
playing Superman however there are some
really cool DC characters that these
actors could play like Lex Luthor
Darkseid Martian Manhunter a new Riddler
a new Joker these are all characters
that are going to be coming to the new
DCU then of course we have characters
like Black Canary Selena Kyle AKA
Catwoman and I actually wouldn't mind
Chris Pratt playing somebody really
really awesome like Deathstroke see a
different side of Chris Pratt the point
is there is many many different awesome
characters that these cast members could
play over at DC the question is who is
going to be a perfect fit for them so
right away if you have anybody in mind
any role in mind for any specific actor
let us know Down Below in the comments
now as far as DC is concerned it does
seem like there's something that fans
need to be aware about and it's the
movies that DC has planned that already
exists in the past universe that DC was
trying to build movies like The Flash 2
and Aquaman 2. these movies are still
happening but they're probably going to
end with these movies despite whatever
we've heard online for example James
Gunn has hinted at very very very much
that Jason Momoa is probably going to be
playing Lobo in the DCU so no more
Aquaman for Jason Momoa also Shazam
exists in the universe in which Ben
Affleck's Batman exists gal gadot's
Wonder Woman Ezra Miller is The Flash
and we know that that universe is going
away and yes Zachary Levi online did say
that there's nothing really to worry
about but what I believe he was
referring to is that Shazam 2 is not
going to be canceled there was some
concern about that but that movie is
still going to be released however after
that I don't think Zachary Levi is going
to continue as Shazam but they're not
going to come out and say that because
that's going to keep some people away
from seeing that movie it's going to
discourage them people essentially will
say well what's the point in going to
see this movie if it's kind of the last
of the franchise and the entire universe
is basically going to reset after well I
think that is pretty much going to
happen now I hope people still go watch
the movie because it'll probably be a
fun movie and Lucy Leo and Helen Mirren
are villains which I'm really really
excited to see however since James Gunn
has basically confirmed he is rebooting
this franchise doing a soft reboot and
essentially recasting younger Justice
League characters I think it's safe to
say that these old characters are going
away or I should say the actors who play
these characters are going away and this
is a good thing it really is it is sad
and it does kind of suck but we need a
fresh reboot we need to start over with
something that has continuity and
connectivity from the very beginning
which is what James Gunn wants to do and
here's the cool thing he's kind of
already done it he's been with Marvel
Studios for a very long time he's
watched what they have done he is really
good friends with Kevin feige Kevin
feige even congratulated him on becoming
the new CEO of DC Studios so he has a
great relationship with the president of
Marvel Studios so he can ask him for
help too if he ever needs anything but
keep in mind James Gunn directed
Peacemaker and the new Suicide Squad
movie both of which were really really
great so I think James Gunn's got it I
think it's all in good hands at this
point in time so let's just wait and see
what he's going to announce next week
and let's cross our fingers for the
Guardians of the Galaxy that not all of
our favorite heroes are going to bite
the bullet in this next movie but if you
have any predictions of your own please
let us know in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
the latest Marvel and DC news for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof